noam chomsky is a linguist a philosopher
a political activist a social critic a
historian and a cognitive scientist
often called the founder of modern
linguistics the fields of analytical
philosophy and cognitive science are
replete with references to chomsky's
work and thoughts click on the timestamp
in the description if you'd like to skip
this intro this is the sixth time that
i've spoken to noam chomsky perhaps this
channel should be called theories of
gnome for those new to this channel my
name is kurt j mungle i'm a filmmaker
with a background in math and physics
explicating or interested in explicating
what are called theories of everything
from a theoretical physics perspective
but as well as analyzing the possible
role consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of the universe
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us if you enjoy witnessing
and engaging in real-time conversation
with other people on the topics of
consciousness philosophy and psychology
physics even then do consider visiting
the discord and the subreddit which are
linked below there's also a link to the
patreon that is
patreon.com if you'd like to support
this podcast as the patrons and the
sponsors are the only reason that i'm
able to do this full time it would be
extremely difficult for me to go in
depth on topics such as string theory or
loop quantum gravity or coming up
geometric unity if not for your support
thank you and that link again is
patreon.com kurt jaimungle with regard
to sponsors there are three algo is an
end-to-end supply chain optimization
software company with software that
helps business users optimize sales and
operations planning to avoid stockouts
reduce return and inventory write downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who's been a huge
supporter of this podcast since near its
inception the second sponsor is
brilliant brilliant illuminates the soul
of math science and engineering through
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences brilliance courses explore
the laws that shape our world elevating
math and science from something to be
feared to a delightful experience of
guided discovery you can even learn
group theory which is what's being
referred to when you hear that the
standard model is predicated on u1 cross
su-2 cross s23 those are called lead
groups technically visit brilliant.org
tow t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription i recommend that you don't
stop before four lessons and i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
that you previously had trouble grocking
the third sponsor is joining us for the
first time and that's curiosity stream
now curiosity stream is like the netflix
for nerds or the hulu for history buffs
or the disney plus for the scientist in
you go to curiositystream.comtoe
to for access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
more on curiosity stream later thank you
and enjoy this destitory conversation
ask me anything with noam chomsky i
think you
reach a lot of people on
interesting topics that it's worth
thinking about
no better answer than that
thank you thank you okay so can we go
live now
yeah all right
okay if you're watching and you can see
this type metal gear
metal gear
this one comes from finding blanks
which of your beliefs gnome chomsky do
you hold most tenaciously that has the
least evidence
well that's hard to answer first of all
there aren't many
beliefs that i hold
tenaciously i think they're all
subject
to question and change
and
as far as i'm aware the
ones i hold most
confidently have
are held on the basis of evidence
so i don't know how to answer
okay then we'll go to question number
three mohit wants to know is
phenomenology such as in the tradition
of husserl an adequate way to study
consciousness or are there other better
ways of studying consciousness today
i think it's a way to study the
nature of consciousness
try to
expel out in
as much detail and subtly as we can
what we're actually conscious of
but there are plenty of other ways to
study consciousness
so for example
efforts to
find its
neural basis
uh
questions about
how far consciousness reaches
the plants have consciousness
if you're a pan psychic the atoms have
consciousness
lots of ways to study the phenomena
it's actually worth mentioning
on the side that
concern for the phenomena of
consciousness
kind of prime concern
is a pretty
modern development
until
probably the
17th century
there wasn't much discussion of
consciousness
and the early discussions were most in
the following centuries were mostly
about
consciousness of what's in our minds
what
internal con
consciousness of the inner workings of
our minds
the modern concern with
qualia you know what's it like to see
the color red and so on
that's pretty much 20th century
and it's moved to the
center of a lot of philosophical
discussion and debate even
called the hard problem
only in very recent times i
don't see much basis for it plenty of
other
deeper problems but anyway there are
many ways to study it
the next question is for number four
from jake watson can you ask him why he
thinks hume was a rationalist
well it depends what we mean by
rationalists the term is
pretty loose but
one
crucial element in the
rationalist empiricist
semi-conflict they overlap a lot
was
the question of the primacy that you
give to
internal structures of the mind
what were loosely called innate ideas
but
remember the term idea was used very
broadly
thoughts and so on
so how much is
internally structured
well hume believed a lot
the uh his
answer to the
paradox of induction that was
prime element of his thinking
was animal instinct we're just built
a certain way
and that way we
make certain
draw certain conclusions from a
variety of evidence
even though there's no logical basis for
it
so from that point of view and he was
also
interested in studying
the internal
built-in nature of the mind
what he called the
secret springs and principles by which
the mind functions
that's
continuous with
rationalist thinking in some ways i
don't really think people can
historical figures can be
easily split into one or another
category
nobody could be a pure empiricist it's
incoherent
some people profess it but they don't
mean it as soon as you look it turns out
it's not the case there considering
internal nature of the mind at
many points actually
leibniz pointed this out in his
critique of
uh john locke and his
new essays oh he says look there's
reference to an invocation of
innate structure all over the place
as there has to be
okay this question comes from the chat
so it's not on your list this is laura
sosa who says forgive a novice here what
are your thoughts on retro causality
quantum entanglement time perception and
precognition studies
well it's an interesting question
about
the only argument i've ever seen
from the sciences
on
why there can't be free will
is
retro causality
the argument that
if
in our
life experience x
precedes systematically y and we take x
to cause y and if it seems that
we're carrying out an act say am i
lifting my finger
uh just
because i decided to do it
at some
level maybe the
you know not the level of experience
there's an argument that
time is reversible
which means that
the
lifting my finger could have preceded
the decision to do it
which seems to conflict with the
idea that i decided to do it
i personally don't think that's
a very persuasive argument but it's uh
it is at least one argument i think
probably the only argument
that comes from the sciences
against the
universal belief which we all have
whether we
deny it or not
that we can make decisions about our
next action
number five
on the list cyborg asks do you think
that the many theories of reference and
meaning that philosophers have developed
over the years such as russell's
descriptive theory [ __ ] case causal
theory semantic externalism etc do you
think they have any real life impact on
how we use language
if not what's the point
i don't think their purpose is to
have a real life impact
their goal is to
explore and understand
the nature of
how
the nature of in particular how language
relates to the world
reliant use of language relates to the
world somehow obviously
question is hell
that's the question of reference
question of meaning is much broader
meaning is a term that
actually is very hard to translate into
other languages most other languages
don't even have that term
but it's a very broad and loose term
about
the general significance of things that
we do
so what about these particular theories
russell's descriptivist theory is uh
basically an effort the the substantive
crucial part of it was his
theory of
singular
definite expressions
and that's been
quite useful in
undermining
uh
misinterpretation of
uh
sentences based on their
surface properties
so that was a useful
contribution to
understanding the
semantics of natural language
the other
ideas that are proposed here i
my own view is that they're based on a
false assumption
uh which undermines them
the false assumption
is that language
has a notion of reference
or denotation
now here we have to make a distinction
distinction was made sharply
17
80 years ago by
peter strawson and others
there's a difference between
reference and referring
reference is a relation
between
an
object
in a system
for language an internal object
something in our minds
like the word
river
and a relation between that
and some extra mental entity
referring is an action
it's the action of
using the refer word river
to refer to the
relito river which i cross on the way to
work
and that's very different that's an act
references a relation
there's no doubt
that human
life has includes the activity of
referring
like i can refer to the chair you're
sitting on
but that
doesn't imply that language has a
relation of reference
a relation between say words
and
mind external objects
and i don't think it does
when you look closely at the
meaning of words
then i'll refer to mind external objects
so if i take a simple sentence like
he's pushing an open door
as a literal meaning and a metaphoric
reading
let's take the literal meaning he's
pushing an open door
well there's one
referential phrase there
open door
what's that
i mean a door is a material object an
open door is an abstract conception
you can't tell by
looking a physicist looking at the world
can't tell whether it's an open door
whether it's an open door depends on how
it functions
how you tend to use it
uh whether you expect it to be closed
tomorrow and so on
so there's no such thing in the world as
an open door
and the same applies to rivers
you can
take the river that i cross on the way
to work
rolito river happens to be i live in
arizona
i've almost never seen any water in it
it has water only when it there's a
heavy very heavy rain
so you can be the reliedo river without
having any water
you can be the really river if the
course is changed or reversed
uh if it's uh
if it's uh
walls are put on the side and it's used
for
commercial vessels it's not a river it's
a canal
uh you can actually harden the surface
and use it for commuting downtown
and then it's a highway
on so you can make huge changes
and it's still a river
you can make slight changes it's not a
river
there's no object in the world that has
those properties
these things were all
investigated to some extent in classical
greece
like aristotle
discussed
uh the notion house
is
i should say that i'm taking a little
bit of license here for aristotle this
was a metaphysical question what is a
house
if we shift to the 17th century
cognitive revolution these
questions were reinterpreted in
cognitive terms and that's what i'm
accepting so what is the concept house
and aristotle's argument is
it's
amount it's an amalgam of matter and
form
the matter is
the bricks the
timbers and so on that a physicist could
find
the form
is the design
the intention of the architect the
characteristic use
the essential nature of what makes it a
house and not something else
well that's in the mind
and many in the collective minds in fact
can't observe that
you take a close look at any word in the
language i think it's the same
it's uh
there just is no relation of reference
that's a
mistaken
concept of contemporary philosophy of
language
it shows up in the names of books like
coins word and object and so on
i think it's just a mistaken conception
and uh
the causal theory the
uh
theory of uh
you know
semantic externalism are
all based on this theory on this concept
and therefore i just don't think they
apply the language
they may apply to invented languages
in fact they
may well apply to the language of
science
or the language of metamathematics
for science
it's kind of a norm
that we try to create theories that do
have a relation of reference
so if a
quantum theorist is talking about
particles
yeah they may not actually know what
they are but which they don't in fact
but they at least hope that they exist
independently of the mind
when a linguist
talks about phonemes let's say
he's hoping that such things exists
somewhere in the world
maybe in the brain but
at least the goal of science is to
create systems which do have reference
but natural language is not
invented by people for a purpose it's a
natural object
it doesn't doesn't have goals
and it's what it is and it doesn't
although we use it for referring it
doesn't seem to have reference
okay the next question number six
kelly girling or jurling
in 1960 gnome's co-author and colleague
george a miller published in his
published this book plans and structure
of behavior
along with eugene gallanter okay has the
formal core idea of the plan as part of
general cognitive functioning been
upheld or shown to be false for humans
for mammals generally what are its
applications and usefulness if any
well it was an interesting
idea i think mostly written by george
miller
uh with the collaboration
it
was an interesting approach to cognition
trying to apply
ideas that had been developed in
the study of language mainly
and
as far as i'm aware it
hasn't been developed any further
or applied in any
significant way
it's
very hard to see what a plan is
or how many plans there are
it's very
the same
say
walking across a room suppose i
plan to walk across the room
how many plans am i making
well thanks to a
gentleman named zeno a few years ago
we know that there are infinitely many
plans in fact continuously many plans i
have a plan to walk halfway across then
halfway to the next distance and so on
and every thing we call a plan is just
a description at
some level we're choosing
of a variety of activities and
intentions
and there's no
real way to determine
how many plans there are what the plans
are to
to matter it's a multivariable
issue and
i don't think as far as i know that the
ideas have been
clarified sharpened or pursued
much beyond
george miller's original conception
okay the next number seven
joe smith is recursion and intrinsic and
universal property of all human e
language as opposed to i language you
may want to tell what the difference
between e and i is
yeah well
actually i invented the terms so i guess
i have some proprietary interest in them
but the term e-language is constantly
used but not in the way that i defined
it
so i'm kind of at a loss to discuss it
i defined e-language to just anything
else
i think we have a coherent
useful important notion of i language
and there are many other ideas about
language
whatever they are so call them
e-language externalized language i also
added
that i didn't think there would ever be
any coherent account of some notion of
ie language
and i think that's been
pretty well verified it's now
30 years
i've never seen a
35 years actually almost 40 years
and i've never seen a coherent
definition of characterization of
e-language
e-language is used
to refer to the
actual
set of
noises that
people produce
but that's not a coherent notion
that changes
every time you and i are talking
or somebody else is talking
so it's just not a serious notion
and i don't think there's anything to
say about it
so i really
can't answer people who
think they understand
what e-language is they're the ones
who'd have to answer
okay we'll get to question number one
back at the top this one comes from sam
thompson what are your thoughts on
marshall stone's maxim one must always
topologize applied to formal language
theory specifically just how much
insight do you think can be gained by
using topological structures in studying
certain well-behaved classes of formal
languages for those watching this is
referred to as stone
duality yeah
well
formal languages or the study of formal
languages is part of mathematics
it's not part of linguistics has some
relation
to the study of language but it's pretty
weak
so you have to ask the same question you
would ask about
any other mathematical concept
so if we go back
to the mid-19th century say
the first time there were
precise definitions given of the
central notion of mathematics the notion
of limit
newton worked with it leibniz worked
with it but they had no clear notions so
proofs are kind of vague but by the
mid-19th century there was a need to
really sharpen clarify what we meant by
limit and there were
topological approaches
which were successful so the most
the big integration and so on use
topological approach to the notion of
limit
so there the answer to the
maxim would be
yes in that case
when applied to formal language theory
we have to ask the same question
is there
a topological approach
that gives us some insight into the
nature of these formal systems
maybe there is
maybe there isn't but
there's nothing
to say about it until
the
the argument is given for a topological
analysis i
don't think there are any but
maybe that there are and i don't know
about them
it's at this point you may be a bit lost
and that's okay there's quite a bit of
jargon to learn a new subject intensely
it helps to get an overview and
curiosity stream acts as an ancilla to
that quest by furnishing a variety of
documentaries on the topics of physics
and consciousness i recommend you watch
stephen hawking's favorite places which
combines quite a few interests of this
channel namely the unification quest in
physics alien life and even artificial
intelligence go to curiositystream.com
toe that is t-o-e for unlimited access
to some of the world's top documentaries
and non-fiction series use the promo
code toe toe and you'll save 25 which
comes out to about 14.99 a year slightly
over a dollar a month and that trounces
any of the other video streaming
platforms the link is below and do let
me know what you think of stephen
hawking's favorite places
this next question comes from chris
langan it's not on the list that you
have
to what extent is scientific discovery
pre-linguistic especially with regard to
intuitive flashes of genius
well i think we can extend that question
to what extent is
all of the most
prosaic
human
thought
pre-linguistic
well actually we know something about
that
not a lot
but there's very strong evidence that
most of our use of language
what you and i are doing now
involves
mental operations
that are beyond the level of
consciousness
well beyond the level of conscious
we can't introspect into them we have no
idea what's going on in our minds
you can only study it
from the outside
the way you study from what's called the
third person perspective
you can study it the way
i can study the chair that you're
sitting on
but i don't have any you know i don't
have any internal
understanding of it now what's going on
in our minds
i mean there are two ways to
try to understand it
one is
introspection the other is scientific
canal theory
from
scientific research and research in
linguistics
we can get some account
of what's going on in our minds
introspectively all we get is that
fragments are coming to consciousness
and then we can build some expressions
out of them
so what's going on internally
to the extent that we understand it
is basically linguistics
but
that just tells us
that there's probably plenty more that
we don't understand
like for example if
suppose i'm trying to decide
uh
what's the best way
to get to drive to work today okay
i
i you i don't know about you but i use
visual images
i see i sort of make a visual map of
the layout of the town uh where there's
likely to be a traffic jam
where there's like to be you know a
detour and then i make up some plan
back to plans but
how much of this is linguistic
we don't have any way to answer
all we know is
somehow these things are going on in our
mind
we can introspect a little bit
there's some scientific results
but it's uh
an area that's extremely difficult to
explore
okay the next question also comes from
chris lang and it's related to this how
does language relate to consciousness is
linguistic self-reference a useful
concept in this regard
well as i said before
consciousness is a
pretty recent topic of extensive thought
uh
going back to what i just said and
answered the list question
one thing we know about language and
consciousness
is that most
of language use is inaccessible to
consciousness
what
you and i are now doing
when we're
and that we're consciously aware of
is a very superficial reflection of
mental activities
going on in the mind
many of which
to the extent we understand them are
linguistic in character
but they're not reaching consciousness
so among the
areas of consciousness
there are things like
my seeing that
there's a chair behind you which i
assume you're sitting on
the way of course don't know it i don't
even know that there's a chair maybe
it's a painting on the back wall but
i interpret it as a chair that you're
sitting on that's conscious
i
understand
the questions that you're reading that's
language and consciousness
but uh
how far
language
reaches to
consciousness or how far consciousness
reaches the language
are pretty open questions
uh the
with some of the properties i mentioned
okay number eight this one comes from
peter glenos in canada many
multiculturalists believe that the state
should actively intervene in the
preservation of cultures
and as much as they do they take on the
assumptions that the assumption that
these cultures are equal
or at least equally worth preserving
however progressives believe that
culture can improve that the culture of
today can be better tomorrow this takes
the opposite presupposition that not all
cultures are equal
because if the culture of tomorrow
wasn't going to be better than the
culture of today we can't call it
progress how can multiculturalism and
progress be compatible
let's start with
equality of people
so from one point of view
people are
for a
decent human being at least
uh people are equal they have equal
rights
like i have the same right
to
pole vault
as an olympic champion as
we both have the same right to do it but
i'll never be an olympic champion we're
not equal in that respect it's not too
late no
i'll be lucky if i can
go a foot high you know but
nevertheless from one point of view
we're all equal from another point of
view we're quite different
and i think
pretty much the same is
true in the case of
cultures and languages
here the questioner crucially put in at
the very least equally worth preserving
well turning that to individuals
at the very least my right to pole vault
is worth preserving
if i find it fun to try okay
but that doesn't mean it's equal to the
olympic champion
and i think the same is true here
each language each culture has its own
intrinsic value
and the people
engaged in that culture using that
language have every right to preserve
enrich their own tradition
uh
imprint including enrich
which means making it better like maybe
they can improve the complex kinship
systems they have
but the kinship systems are worth
preserving
for them because it's a crucial part of
their lives for all of us because it
gives us insight
into the nature of human cognitive
capacity
human nature human relations
so i think
though on the surface it looks like a
contradiction i think it's resolvable
every
culture every language like every person
has
should be
equally worth preserving
meaning
granted all appropriate rights including
the including the right to develop and
flourish and improve
like for me
i'm not going to do it but the chance to
improve my pole vaulting from
one foot to a foot and a half
should have that right
uh
but
and the same with
my culture a lot of ways and which could
be improved i think
we could mention plenty of them
but
they're all
contributing they're all
aspects of
the human general human capacity
which have the right to flourish and
develop in their own ways
question number 44
while i don't like to ask you political
questions we'll get somewhat political
john doe asks would gnome ever consider
giving sam harris a televised discussion
on the role of religion and the us
military adventurism in creating the
present situation in the middle east
well i often have discussions on these
matters
i don't know about televised television
doesn't do these things but on
podcasts on programs like this
constantly discussing
questions of this kind
had a couple this morning in fact
should it be with sam harris
i don't know why i
the little i know about him i
don't think it would be a very valuable
discussion
but i'm involved in them all the time
and i
of course they select only a small
fraction
i mean i have enough invitations to
for a 96-hour day easily
so i have to pick just a few
and
pick my priorities i picked this one not
other ones it's my judgment about what's
value to pursue
and
without
wanting to comment on sam harris from
the little i know about him it hasn't
seemed to be worth pursuing
well i'm grateful that you said yes to
this we'll go on to the next one which
is 45 when commenting regarding sam
harris before you mention that he's
racist however criticizing certain
interpretations of islam isn't the same
as criticizing muslims
how can one criticize interpretations of
islam without being called a racist
the way
muslims commonly do
the way they
i mean i'm jewish
i criticize many aspects of judaism
doesn't mean of anti-semite
the most
a dedicated
religious jew
criticizes other aspects of judaism
so the orthodox revenant in israel which
basically runs all
religious affairs in the country
they're very harshly critical of
the
kind of judaism that
is pervasive in the united states
reformed duties and conservative duties
and as far as they're concerned that's
not even judaism it's uh heresy
well they're not racist they're not
anti-semites so that's the way to do it
are also other ways of do it where you
say
islam by its nature
is evil destructive
one or another thing that's racist
does one have to be
muslim to criticize islam or can one
not be of the faith and still criticize
it question
i can perfectly will
criticize
jihad the jihadi ideology for example
and many other aspects of islam or
christianity
there are elements of christianity which
in my view are abhorrent so i can
criticize them without being a racist
okay one more political question that's
the next one 46
number 46
someone asks chomsky hates big pharma
and big corporations
but wants to insist people patronize
pfizer moderna johnson and johnson and
so on
why trust these companies and the
government in this area given there are
many independent virologists
and vaccine developers who advise
against mass vaccination during a
pandemic such as geert vandenbosch
where's
question number 46 46
46 yep
okay
all i
why these companies and the government
given that there are some independent
virologists and
vaccine developers who oppose max
vaccination
well the answer if i'm in favor of
vaccination is because of the
overwhelming evidence overwhelming
that vaccination
radically
radically reduces infection
and
cuts back radically cuts back
severe disease and contagion
and also reduces the pool for
mutation i think the evidence on that is
quite overwhelming
has nothing to do with your attitudes
towards
big pharma or government
just
simply take a look at the
take a look at the map that appears in
every day
in the new york times
about hot spots this morning for example
uh what this remarkable facts sean
the places that are the worst hot spots
are shown in red
then
you less bright colors for others
one thing that's striking
dramatic
about the global hot spots is that the
united states is the prime offender in
the world
stands and there are a few other places
scattered around that are red but the
big
dark red areas are the united states
that is an astonishing fact
this is the richest country in the world
most powerful country in the world
has natural advantages that
no other country has
and it's the worst place in the world
for dealing with the pandemic
if you look more closely at the map of
the united states you see exactly why
the red spots
are essentially the old confederacy
and a few outliers like wyoming and
idaho with
republican
run by republicans
what does that tell you
you look a little closer you see these
are the states where people are refusing
vaccination
then if you go even closer
you look into the hospitals in alabama
idaho what you find is
desperate
totally desperate nurses and doctors
trying somehow to deal
with the flood of cases
almost entirely unvaccinated
overwhelming
first studies are just beginning to come
out came out yesterday
of
the
sharp rise
in covet infections
among children too young to get
vaccinated now these are preliminary
studies so
just
a surmise so far but so far what they
showed
is exactly what you could predict
these are the children of unvaccinated
parents
okay
now around around the world you find the
same thing
that's why health officials
everywhere
are calling for more extreme vaccination
now there are a few people who say there
are some that's mentioned who say well
there are possible dangers in
vaccination
that's true of vaccination generally
it's true of polio it's true of measles
there are possible dangers
but
now we turn to an interesting
sociological phenomenon
in the past
there have been plenty of vaccinations
and vaccine mandates
so for schools
in the united states i presume other
countries there's a vaccine mandate
for
sending a kid to school
you can't send a kid to school who
hasn't had the polio vaccine
which is correct
that
protects children from the danger
now yes
there's some danger in polio vaccines
it's always been understood
same kind of dangers that are pointing
out today but nobody ever paid attention
to it before
so we have a strange sociological
phenomenon
right now there are major movements
major movement most of them on the far
right but the left as well
saying we have to pay attention to the
kind of dangers that have always been
known
and we have to pay attention to the few
outliers who say well maybe these
dangers outweigh the benefit of
vaccinations and we should ignore the
fact that literally millions of people
are dying
from lack of vaccination
now that's a sociological problem
why is it different now than ever before
why is there a group of people who
eagerly latch on
to any
straw of evidence that there might be
something wrong with mass vaccination
and there are always such draws why is
that happening
my suspicion is it's another
reflection of a
collapse of the social order
and a serious decline
of the general environment of
rational discourse and
civilized interchange shows up in many
areas and i suspect that this is part of
it
do you think we should force vaccines or
mandate them
i don't think we should force vaccines
but i think we should protect people
from those who decide
i want to be free to endanger others
if people don't want to be vaccinated
fine they should have the decency to
segregate themselves
go somewhere
don't go to it don't go to a concert
where you endanger others
okay
if you don't want your kid to have a
polio vaccine
you're not forced to do it but don't
send them to school to endanger other
children
so i'm in favor of vaccine mandates i
think they're crucial for ending
at least trying to contain this
disease which is rampant in the united
states
because of the
strange sociological phenomenon that i
mentioned
the unusual breakdown
of
the social order
and
rational civilized discourse which we
see in many areas
take a look at the polls of republicans
it's astonishing
about a quarter of republicans
think the government is run by
an elite of the sadistic pedophiles
who are carrying out experiments on
young children
uh
i mean
it's total madness you know this is
higher than the percentage of people who
support organized religions
that runs through
i mean a majority of republicans say
they're not going to get vaccinated
well there are also
sectors of the left which
have been caught up in this
strange disorder
and as i said are eagerly seeking
any fragment of evidence
however weak that might question the
overwhelming evidence of the efficacy of
vaccines
okay we'll get to question 43
harjot 43 harjot singh i don't think
i've ever seen chomsky talk about
stoicism and i'm interested to hear what
he has to say
well
the reason i haven't talked about it is
i don't have much to say about it
except
wittgenstein's
adage in the last sentence of the
tractatus
if you have nothing to say
keep quiet
so
could comment on it but i have nothing
of any interest to say about it
okay we'll get to question 30
3030
from john clever
30.
yep
what are your thoughts on the dominance
of the analytical school of philosophy
over thinkers like heidegger husserl
kierkegaard why aren't there more
continental universities
that means
i presume in the united states
or in the west generally and the britain
and the anglophone areas
in the united states
well there
the reason is that
philosophers and
most other
educated people have found more
interest in
the analytics school than in
heidegger hustle and curator you can
study them um there are universities
where
these are
you know you can major in them do a phd
in them but it's not the dominant
school in the uh
in the anglophone areas it's mainly
britain in the united states and
australia yeah
the reasons are what i said people found
greater interest in it
i must speaking personally i share that
opinion
i mean i find
not heidegger who i don't get much out
of but husserl and kierkegaard are
interesting
uh customers could be considered in the
analytic tradition
i don't know why he's put there
a cure card is
for me is interesting literature
uh
i don't it's not what i would call
the kind of doesn't raise the kind of
philosophical questions that i'm
interested in
but
read it learn something from it fine
okay we'll go to 28
george holiday what is your view on
animal agriculture how can one reconcile
supporting immoral industries while
trying to live a morally good life
well
that's a fact about life
we cannot live our lives
without carrying out actions which we
know are immoral
like talking on this discussion
which is using energy
and use of energy
is destroying the environment
uh okay
so i talked before about driving to work
i have no other way to get to drive to
get to work can't go by a bicycle can't
walk
can't take mass transportation because
there isn't any
so i drive to work
well i know
that's harming the environment
i suppose you have an iphone
i don't happen to have one but most
people do
if you have an iphone
you're
contributing
to the slaughter of millions of people
in the eastern congo
uh where the basic minerals are
and where
warring tribes are
killing people to get hold of them
so that the multinationals who are
hovering over their shoulders can
get the minerals and turn them into your
iphone
just about every aspect of life
we're doing something that we know is
immoral
that's a fact and there's no way to
avoid it
uh absolutely no way if you want to
survive
well
that means we have to make decisions
to make choices
to do
to to be as moral as we can be within
the limits of
maintaining
a passable existence
on animal agriculture
i think
you could ask the same about plant
agriculture
plant agriculture is
not a panacea
it's destroying agricultural lands
destroying habitats
leading to the development of
coronaviruses for example
plenty of problems with animal with
plant agriculture
plenty more with animal agriculture the
way animals are treated is obscene
also very harmful to us
like one of the main problems in
contemporary human life
very serious one
on a par with
probably on a par with
global warming nuclear war and others
is the
development of
antibiotic resistance
organisms
uh
well that's serious
it's beginning to
reach the point where
health officials scientists are
concerned that
in a
maybe
a couple of decades
it'll be impossible to carry out any
surgical procedures
or any most other medical interventions
because they'll simply be too dangerous
because of
antibiotic resistant organisms
well where's antibiotic resistance
coming from mostly from overuse of
antibiotics
and most of that
is in animal
or agriculture
you pack
cows and chickens and pigs into
virtually unsurvivable conditions
it's going to be disease spread
well you're trying to make profit
what you do is not
let them live on the range pack them in
tight and pack them full of antibiotics
the organisms develop resistance to the
antibiotics
pretty soon you have
the flood of antibiotic
resistant organisms so we're killing
ourselves
openly knowledgeably our children we're
killing them
okay
is it the right thing to do
only if you think
you want
that your goal in life is to murder your
grandchildren
because that's what we're doing
well there are answers
you can have
range-free animals for example but you
can stop the overuse of antibiotics
you could allow animals to have
a decent existence
up to the point yes where you kill them
for eating should we stop keeping them
for eating probably but we're not at
that stage of civilization
it would mean mass genocide for humans
most people don't have the luxury
to
uh live a vegetarian diet that's a
luxury some people can do it
okay maybe that's their priority
uh there are plenty i should say that if
we're interested in
animal life
there's a much more important way to
save it
than a vegan diet
that's combating global warming
we're killing species
at a phenomenal level
a level that hasn't been seen for 65
million years
since the fifth extinction
and if we continue
heating the
climate
we're going to wipe out
incom and
uncountable numbers of animals species
we don't even know about
most of our species we're never going to
heard of
okay
best way to protect animals
is to
quickly
settle the problem
of
overheating the environment
and then there are other things like
decent conditions for animals
cutting back shifting as much as
possible to
plant-based diets ensuring that the
plant-based diets don't
have
the their own serious problems like
those i mentioned
all of that are things that can be done
but to try to live a moral life
is in fact hopeless
there is no way to do it
nobody's done it ever in history
nobody knows how to do it today
comes from john tillo what are the
possible reasons for a person to acquire
fluent mandarin after being in a car
crash so spontaneous language
acquisition after some brain injury
well that's a story somebody who didn't
know mandarin chinese had a car crash
and
knew mandarin chinese
at this point i think it would be
useful
to go back to david hume
who was raised before
and his
essay on miracles
he said if we're rational people
and we get a report of a miracle
which is in
radical violation
of well-established laws and principles
we have to balance
how much do we trust the story
and how much do we trust
established
developed science understanding
and his argument was in the case of what
are called miracles
the balance is almost invariably against
miracles
and this is a miracle
it's uh inconsistent with everything
that's known
in biology and
in
anthropology and linguistics
totally inconsistent
if it were true all of science would
have to be thrown out
so we have a choice
do we throw out
basically everything we know
or do we question the report
i mean i'm with hume on that one
the next one carl how does he think
about his legacy concerning the
universal grammar theory as well as how
the field
has evolved on human language formation
some people call gnome an essentialist
and even go so far as saying chomsky
stood in the way of progress can you
give some context to the theory's birth
and how have things progressed
well a universal grammar first of all
is a term that
has a traditional usage
and a traditional usage it was
generalizations about language that hold
most of the time
that's a descriptive field that doesn't
get very far
you take a look at
languages on the surface they appear to
vary all over the place
so you don't get very many
generalizations that are
generally valid some and they're of
interest but not much
in the modern period the last
60 or 70 years the term universal
grammar has been adapted to a new
context
it's the theory
of the
uh
innate faculty of language
we you human beings have a faculty of
language
that's why we're doing what we're now
doing
it has no analogues in other organisms
nothing in the higher apes nothing in
birds nothing anywhere they have their
own cognitive capacities often far
beyond ours but this is one capacity
they totally lack
this is about as well established as
anything is so there is a faculty of
language
well next question what's the theory of
the faculty of language what is it
the name for this theory is universal
grammar
to question universal grammar
is to say
there's no reason why an infant acquires
language but it's pet cat
uh with the same experience doesn't
acquire language it's a miracle
well if you don't believe in miracles
you believe in universal grammar so you
may not believe think you do but you do
then the question comes
well what's
the legacy concerning use of universal
grammar
it's a kind of theory that began
to be explored
in the basically in the 1950s
late 40s
over the course of these years there
have been many advances
the kinds of conceptions that we had at
the very beginning
have been sharply improved changed
modified we now have
much better conception of what the
language faculty is
uh it's not finished of course more
progress should be made
so there's no legacy the legacy is just
keep working on it and try learning more
uh people who say it's essentialist have
are confused somehow
it's no more essentialist than saying
humans have a visual system
yes they do it's different from the
visual system of insects
okay
nothing essentialist about that it's a
fact about the world
uh i can't imagine how it
can stand in the way of progress it is
progress
it's the progress in understanding the
language faculty
so
there's a there's a huge what the
question reflects a very large
literature
but it's plainly based on some kind of
misunderstanding
because the actual
issues are
my view crystal clear have been made
clear over and over
in these fields the
so-called soft sciences generally
there's an awful lot of confusion
uh it shows up in
all kinds of ways i mean it was true of
the hard sciences too in earlier years
but
they've gradually
succeeded in overcoming a lot of it
take in fact biology
uh if you go back 50 years 60 years
it was very widely believed in biology
that organisms can vary
in almost every imaginable way
and that each organism has to be studied
on its own without prejudice
same view is held about language
languages can vary
almost any possible way each one has to
be studied on its own
well in biology that's known to be
totally false
turns out in more recent years it's been
learned that
there is what's called deep conservation
basic genetic structures are conserved
for a long
all the way back to the beginning of
life sometimes
there are laws of form which
sharply restrict the possible the nature
of possible organisms
existing
for life forms
complex life
since
the cambrian explosion
half billion years ago
fundamentally very similar you know very
very much
it's gotten so far that there are even
suggestions which are taken not accepted
but taken seriously that there might be
a universal genome one genome for all
organisms with minor variations
that's
kind of the direction that the study of
universal grammar has gone
what looked like endless variety
let's begin to study it more deeply
turn out to be deep seated
hidden uniformities
uh principles that apply very broadly
seem to give different results on the
surface but due to
very superficial things
and the fundamental part of language
may turn out that there's only one
and that everything
that varies is just something on the
surface can't prove that but it's going
in that direction
this question comes live
it's from deborah strayer who asks does
gnome have any questions for us
so i'm assuming she wants to know if you
have questions that you think
the audience should be considering
what is my question
my question is
why don't you engage yourself more fully
to solve the
immediate crises that threaten
literally threaten human existence
we may be finished in a couple of
generations
we're in
one of them
i mentioned
the rise of
antibiotic resistant bacteria
it's not going to kill all life on earth
but it'll
make it
radically different from it is now
so let's get to work on it
future pandemics
very likely that future pandemics are
coming
the more that people are unvaccinated
the greater the chance
that new pandemics will new
something like the delta variant or
others will arise
maybe come some that are
beyond the level of
vaccination and any form that we
understand so let's do something about
that
let's make sure that people get
vaccinated and protect themselves
then come the big questions
what about heating the environment
if we continue on our present course
there's every reason to believe
that
pretty soon we'll reach irreversible
tipping points
at which point
it's just an expansion
of the process of overheating the
environment
which
in a not too distant future will
undermine the possibility of organized
human life
meanwhile slaughtering huge numbers of
other species
then there's the problem of nuclear war
very serious and increasing
uh
what are we doing about it
provocative actions
which are increasing the dangers of war
creating new weapon systems which are
extremely dangerous
and again
uh things like space age space
militarizing space and so on
all very dangerous well
all of these problems have to be met
quickly
there's no delay
so my question is
why not
realize this
and devote yourselves seriously to
trying to address it
and i'm afraid i'm gonna have to
leave at that point i have another
interview coming along
thank you so much professor
do you mind answering question 21 before
you go the last one 21 it's william
patterson 21 william patterson because
we spoke about wittgenstein before so
i'd be interested to know his thoughts
on kripkenstein's
problem of the rule following paradox
well actually
i've written about it about 35 years ago
but the essential point is
a misunderstanding
of the no true notion
of rule and rule following that is
pervasive in the philosophical
literature
extreme and wittgenstein
kripke took it over
it's just a misunderstanding of the
rules of the notion rule of language
so the model that's basically used is
something like
traffic signals
stop on red you know
don't turn left on red
that's a rule
that we're aware of
and that we can think about and follow
or we can violate you can go through a
red light okay
rules of language aren't like that at
all
uh so there's
let's take a concrete example
let's say uh
john stole
many books from the library
okay
many books were stolen from the library
both of them can mean
that the library should have more gourds
so that people won't be stealing books
from it
just a lot of books that john is
stealing
suppose i say
many books are easy to steal from the
library
doesn't have that meaning
many books mean some specific books
maybe the
the books on biology
those are easy to steal
totally different meaning
well that we know that
and we know it following rules
the rules are
unconscious
can't introspect into them
they're only beginning to be understood
in fact
turns out an
intricate
interaction of
uh
principles of computational efficiency
and
certain properties of language interact
to yield these results
those are rules of language
kind of like the rules of vision
let's say
you get a couple of
stimulations on your retina from
static eye movements and you see a
person
okay that's following rules that's what
the rules of language are like they're
just parts of theories of explaining the
nature of
uh in this case our language system
that's not what wittgenstein had in mind
that's not what kripke had in mind
so the kind of problems they raised just
don't arise
they're talking about some other kind of
system that has nothing to do with
language vision or other biological
properties
and that's pervasive in
philosophy of language
just as
the assumption that there's a notion of
reference is pervasive
and it's very it's leading in all the
wrong directions in my opinion so i
don't i simply don't think these
questions arise
thank you sir have a great day
yup
take care
okay i'll stick around for a couple more
minutes and read what's going on in the
chat
in case you're interested after this i'm
likely going to be recording
a reading and a commentary on raymond
smallian's is god a taoist
raymond's raymond smalling is one of my
somewhat like an idol
douglas hofstetter and raymond smallian
are two people that i would like to
speak to most on this channel raymond
however is
he's no longer with us he died i think
in 2017
and not
as many people know about his work that
i think should so if i could help
popularize or
help make more popular his work
that would be great
thank you zeno thank you david thank you
channel
war horse
thank you laura thank you nate
okay
thank you everyone if you would like to
see more
conversations like this then please do
consider going to patreon.com
the link is in the live chat as well as
the description as the patrons and the
sponsors are what allow me to do this
full-time i've been going at it fairly
hard recently so you'll get a slew of
interviews especially in september and
early october
then the plan is to take some
time off in november and december but
when i say time off i just mean that i'm
not going to be on screen i'll be
studying
there's far less pressure when i study
and it's
i enjoy that plenty
okay nate gibson wants to know what
happened to yoshibok and donald hoffman
donald hoffman is unavailable he's
unavailable for a few months he was
available something happened and he's
unavailable
now yoshibok is still down to do it we
just have to wait on hoffman who may not
be available until about 2022
maybe q2 of 2022
we'll see
steven wallace i
try on an almost monthly basis to get
douglas hofstadter he responds to my
emails but he politely says no each time
i'm
i always tell him that i'm
glad he still at least lets me know no
instead of ignoring me completely
okay thank you everyone
have a great day